What Colombians symbolize
duelta, Edo,
Lugo,
the duelta techno Centro,
1 emblem
kosdomese,
osdo,
Celtic club,
in 1 first yellow,
dye bermeyo background,
then changed to dark blue and eightie,
blue Celeste,
as the Galician flag.
Over osdouxcés is the royal crown
in,
or background to Cruz de Santiago,
which at one time was,
and by sisoa,
or teammate odo,
Lugo, tendú,
ascores,
Blue, Ever, mello,
are ascores that appear,
I do not understand, on the flag
of Lugo province,
eh,
I have 2 other important elements,
that we see larger,
the older versions of,
on the right there is 1 bomb,
represents,
or former Sporting powder magazine Lugo,
on the left,
the chalice of Lugo gymnastics.
Of those 2 teams I started 1,953,
or Lugo sports club,
that we will crack down on bad guys,
or dode for pode,
lover in our profile